es ist kurz vor 1
[Applaus]
mein name ist wir kommen heute zu einem
neuen video hab mir gedacht dass ich das
hier schon länger nicht mehr gemacht
habe und es kann eigentlich ganz gut bei
euch an und zwar reagiere ich wollte mal
wieder auf die aktuellen youtube trend
luca reagiert
super reagiert
super reagiert auf
als reformer das er auf you tube dafür
steht in seinem namen aufwärtstrend in
deutschland haben wir amerikaner
probieren zum ersten mal deutsche
süßigkeiten hh video von emrah der die
relativ unregelmäßig ort da bin ja ich
jedoch komischerweise jedes wort im
titel irgendwie groß geschrieben sogar
probieren
da gross wichtigen deutschland komplett
gutgeschrieben und hh ok mega coole idee
zu bieten hat etliche wirklich gegen
welche amerikanischen bürger genommen
und hat die einmal vor die kamera
gesetzt die haben dann deutsche
möglichkeiten die wirklich eine mega
geile idee und ich feier dieses video am
radar gibt's von mir auf jeden fall den
ruinen der woche auf platz zwei haben
minister wissen wo die wahrheit über all
die klingt jetzt nicht so interessant
auf platz drei lief leute einfach in
einen trennen um youtube ein autounfall
im live und polizei geht gegen
pressefreiheit vor dem ipo pony
unbedingt anschauen ob nadja maleh ich
kämpfe gegen
wtf
das video spielt sich ab wenn man drüber
geht dann ist das denn der fall das ist
megageil auf platz fünf haben wir eine
heirat von marin und probiert auf 6
haben wir einen cdu politiker auch
fertig hattrick
der macht videos reicht es wurde gleich
auf tests gegen die wieder videos was
jetzt mutig hochfeld musiker geworden
dann haben wir auf platz acht
er macht auch wieder video überhaupt
nichts gegen simon oder gegen tsv oder
so aber mich wundert dass einfach von
wissen in welchen jahre lang geführt
nichts gehört hat wie man reagiert
hierauf ein video von dem frank buß und
schaut sich das hier an und irgendwann
kommt hier und da über die lustig aber
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eigentlich macht es nur ein anderer
schneidet das zusammen das ist mega das
entspannte leben könnt ihr vielleicht
auch meine videos
dann haben wir hier ein amerikaner auf
der deutschen autobahn dann haben wir
hier die daily short tracker noah und
dann haben wir ein mir vor den preis und
freunde hat es wirklich ist mein
lieblings kanal auf youtube da kam ich
mich eigentlich wäre gerne ein video
hochgeladen namen machen niemals leim um
drei uhr nachts in klammern guide wir
sehen schon das video 12345 weg
werbeanzeigen gibt leute die schalten
mehr gibt leute die schaltwege breakball
springboard macht niemals um 3 uhr drei
juroren mache niemals um 3 uhr 3 uhr
oder prozent 300 wagen jäger leiwen
marvin
calvin und marvin und ich wollte immer
noch nicht mehr wert aber ich würde
sagen freunde wie schon öfter man das
video rein will
[Musik]
alles wäre
wir können die eigentlich abonnenten
haben
der eine typ geboren im keller der
andere schlussetappe um wahrscheinlich
töten wow wow wow
er wollte dass wir jetzt alles
aufschreiben zu machen
sechs kerzen der schale inzwischen hat
man ein bisschen durch machen jetzt mit
den schleim und jetzt jetzt hier
passiert ihnen die wasserfreunde als ich
noch nie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
leute meinen ich ja auch da gibt es für
die schlimmste aller zeiten gibt reicht
alle gewinner der vergangenen jahre und
gibt es einfach mal
[Musik]
aber ich meine freunde wie youtube also
als wenn das ganze entwickelt wäre und
ja wir gehen da ganz unvoreingenommen
weiterhin durch video
[Applaus]
bei bern
was ist los ist
[Applaus]
oben angekommen jetzt gehen in den
keller waschmaschine
ich würde sagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt wird noch ein bisschen weiter
durch video wie sinnierte unten passiert
nein als nur freunde ich bin jetzt mal
ein bisschen zurückgegangen und wir
gleich ein paar sekunden jetzt schauen
wir mal ob es wirklich 83 wenn jetzt
nicht 83 die mühe gemacht haben die uhr
umzustellen
es ist kurz vor eins ich dachte wirklich
die ganze zeit gekommen zumindest auf
die idee dann euro uhren umzustellen
oder irgendwie ich mein schauspielern
könnte jena wurde hu an der bande 00 55
ist seit ihr wenn ihr fällt dann fällt
doch wenigen richtig oder denn das video
auf machen niemals frei um 0.55 nach
also ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung was
dieses video soll ich weiß auch nicht
wie die 824 tausend abonnenten haben
können aber ich muss wirklich sagen also
einem content beschweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger also die
waren jetzt die mithelfen den trend der
name ihrer freiwillig sache in hamburg
einen plan b die banknoten donald trump
kiew bei phonak video also irgendwas auf
arabisch oder so glaube ich und leicht
wieder dort das neue iphone vorgestellt
also vielleicht wurden irgendwelche
informationen billig oder sohn da ich
selber apple fan bin ohne das nicht
irgendwie wirklich zu machen oder durch
aber ich arbeite nur mit apple weniger
natürlich relativ gespannt schauen die
informationen zum iphone abgeben
für die informationen zum iphone 800
video mit einem arabischen welt vor dem
kanal day abdullah 20 in den trend
31.000 aufrufe hat auf allen iphone 8
und video ist er wie er irgendwie
deutsche grammatik erklärt
youtube
was
ist frei
rennen haben wir noch ein paar andere
video die typischen minecraft
verdächtigen kuchen tv hochgeladen sind
die performance porsche 964 jetzt ohne
spaß machte auto gerade ich feiere
einfach alte autos so was von viel mehr
dieses ganze neue future design audi hat
ja vor ein paar tagen eine art
vorgestellt und das ist ja ganz schön
und gut dass sich die leute hinten also
hinlegen können und dann haben sie ein
ipad mache ich wenn diese guten alten
autos hammergeil ist aber ein anderes
thema meine damen und herren wir drücken
den trend klagen über etwas hochgeladen
strafen leitmarkt moreno real madrid
news einige theorien anders felski cups
[Musik]
ja
spieler wie sie verdient er mit einem
jahresgehalt von rund sechs millionen
euro dieser typ verdient 6 millionen
euro im jahr dadurch dass er fußball
spielen nichts anderes machen also
natürlich generiert sich ein preis bis
dinger halt immer durch angebot und
nachfrage sehr logisch also ein
unternehmen zahlreichen angestellten
sage ich mal natürlich das ist bei
fußball und bei youtube allgemein zu
müssen anders ein arbeitgeber seinen
arbeitnehmern wie viel er für die
leistung war sie alt angebracht hält
halb sechs millionen euro bekommt dieser
typ initiative einander dafür dass er
fußball spielen kann nicht mal den ball
weg war hoch halten sogar meine kleine
schwester besser natürlich muss man
sagen einander falls ihnen kennt der
verteidiger der muss nicht unbedingt
hoch halten können aber das ist
richtiger filigrantechniker dann haben
wir hier noch irgendwas wegen rapper
wieder im knast ist dann haben wir hier
eine vorstellung von menschen haben hier
noch mal wieder minecraft lachen und das
war's und dass die trends der woche wo
eigentlich alles nur voll mit hamburg
ist dazu leitet allerdings hier auch
wieder meine damen und herren ich wollte
mal wieder einfach auf trend reagiert
und habe mir gedacht hey ich ja ich
reagiert hat wenn ich heute mal wieder
auf trendwende euch gefallen hat öfter
haben wollten das gerne mal leica
schreibt in die kommentare
reaktion findet jetzt die eingeblendet
wenn die da drauf blick könnte meinen
kanal kostenlos abonnieren dadurch
verpasste keine videos mehr und wenn ihr
schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die
glocke neben abonniert unter dem video
hier klicken weil dann bekommt die
benachrichtigung wenn ich das hochladen
finde ich auch mein job eingeblendet und
hier unten ist ein weiteres video
verlinkt